is there a set formula for the YouTube
algorithm a lot of people complain that
the YouTube algorithm sucks for example
people get popular overnight versus
those who've been posting consistently
really how should we be thinking about
the algorithm yeah you know as mutual
friend Todd Beaupre likes to say when
everyone succeeds it's because of them
when everyone is in trouble is because
of the algorithms because of him so I
think that's just like as creators
that's just our coping mechanism and I
totally totally get that but I think
like the best way to look at the YouTube
algorithm is all the algorithm tries to
do is to understand the audience and
audience behaviors so it wants to see
like which videos of the audience
enjoying and part of that is competitive
it's like if we both make videos the
audience they have agency they get to
choose they can click on your video or
my video they have limited time and
attention and if they watch your video
for longer than my video and maybe watch
another one of your videos afterwards
your video is going to do better than my
video and the algorithm is going to
understand that it's going to understand
videos that you watch so it's understand
what that video is videos people who
watch videos similar to you but haven't
seen that video yet and then it's going
to rank that based on things like
satisfaction and personalized set of
rankings based on like what you enjoy
what you interacted with in the past and
it's going to decide which of those
videos to show you and if you think
about it YouTube doesn't push videos for
creators it pulls videos for viewers I
think as creators that's always hard to
wrap our heads around we think we make
this beautiful video and it's the
algorithm's job to push it in front of
as many people as possible when really
the algorithm serves the viewers and
when they come to YouTube it fills their
phone or it fills their computer screen
with you know at first maybe up to eight
different videos and which one are you
gonna click on you know your video might
be in the bottom right and they see like
a Marquez video or a Jimmy video or a
Michelle carre video or maybe they see
your video and they click on that I got
that impression I didn't get that click
so I think that's the thing that would
be helpful for creators to understand
yeah highlighting some quotes
don't think about the algorithm think
about the audience and a better question
than why did the algorithm not like this
video is why didn't my audience or wider
audience I want to reach like this video
so replace audience or replace algorithm
with audience two things number one I've
had too much coffee today number two if
you have not seen our free master class
yet you're gonna love it if you're
serious about growing your YouTube
channel just go to
thinkmasterclass.com for a one hour Deep
dive on-demand YouTube strategy class
it's sick and uh I'm gonna go refill my
coffee hope to see you on the class